the league of nations created after
world war one to provide an
international forum to resolve disputes
and to deter future wars it famously did
none of those things perhaps more famous
though is the fact that the united
states despite its leadership being the
most outspoken proponents for the league
didn't join which raises the pretty
obvious question why not why did the
united states refuse to join the league
of nations so like most peculiarities in
american history this one can be traced
back to congress during the first world
war president wilson had presented his
14-point plan for the post-war world
this included principles like the right
to self-determination armament reduction
and of course the creation of a league
of nations to arbitrate any future
issues to make sure the conflict on that
scale never happened again and wilson
was extremely proud of these ideas and
he was confident that the
democratic-controlled congress would
pass this and they just lost the
midterms and so by the time the
versailles peace negotiations were
ongoing wilson had to deal with a
hostile congress which wasn't going to
pass anything without any serious
modifications thus led by senator henry
lodge the republicans asked for some
modifications to the charger of the
league of nations before they'd agree to
join the primary issue was that members
of the league were required to use
military force against aggressive
military states if the league demanded
it which lodge in his peers or as an
infringement on american autonomy wilson
believed that everything that had been
negotiated during the versailles
conference was fine as it was and so
refused to change anything in fact
joining the league was bundled in with
peace with germany meaning that america
couldn't formally be at peace unless
congress agreed to both at once wilson
tried to get around this deadlock not by
changing his mind that would be silly
but by travelling around the country and
drumming up support the idea was that
the league would resonate with americans
who would in turn pester their
representatives until they agreed with
wilson this didn't work and wilson never
got anywhere with passing the treaty
wilson was succeeded as president by
warren g harding who at first wanted to
join the league providing it couldn't
force america into war but as time went
on support for the league dwindled and
so harding signed a separate peace
treaty with germany and push for
independent agreements to make the world
safer the most notable of these
agreements was the washington naval
treaty which limited the size of the
great powers navies in august 1923
harding left his position as u.s
president to focus on his new passion of
being dead and his vice president calvin
coolidge took over coolidge was a fierce
proponent of kicking the league of
nations can down the road and he largely
tried to keep america distant from
european affairs and after this the
issue had very little importance to the
american people and even less so when
great depression the league proved
itself to be powerless in the face of
japanese italian and german aggression
which meant that american leadership had
no interest in joining such a weak
organization and by the time world war
ii had rolled around americans had
forgotten all about it although after
the war america would go on to join the
league's successor the united nations
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly moneymaker mr wolf sky chappelle
jerry landon jordan longley adam stalter
rob d martin gareth turner wyan hockey
captain cydog winston k wood spencer
lightfoot boogily wiggly aaron the white
gustav swan marvin cassell robert wetzel
caution wolfe matthew shipley marcus
asner alex schwinn maggie paxkowski the
mcwhopper anthony beckett coppertone
spinning three plates moe charles the
first ben evanson and scottish trekkie